I would categorize the risks into a few
different buckets I think
first you know it's the socioeconomic
risk from the large-scale societal shift
that the technology will bring that's
often what technology does that doesn't
mean you should stand in the way of it
but it just needs to make sure that
we're cognizant of it and provide people
with the skills they need to flourish in
a world that is being changed by
technology I think the second is the
risk of misuse and that is whether it's
open source models or otherwise you know
the ability that they well they can be
used as tools to generate this
information or identify and exploit
cyber vulnerabilities or create harmful
content or deep fakes or child sexual
abuse that's a kind of second category I
think the third question would be tool
use whereby Foundation models can be
used to activate capabilities in the
real world and then the last category is
what people would describe as capability
overhangs and that kind of Trends into
the area of more existential risk
because there's just a you know a lack
of understanding at this point about
what the potential of these models might
be yeah obviously separates all of that
the National Security risk which I'm
sure Donald acknowledge I appreciate and
limiting what I can say but I think
thinking about it in those four
categories is probably the right way to
to go about it thank you and you've
convened an international safety Summit
uh for the culture are you intending
that to be a summit of like-minded
countries like the US and Japan perhaps
or is it for all countries a bit like
the international atomic energy
Authority that includes countries like
China and Russia which we want to have
in mind I think look I think in the
first instance
mainly what we're trying to do is
acknowledge that there is a global
Dimension to this Challenge and AI
doesn't respect National borders
countries
are at varying stages of their thinking
about how we can put guard rails in
place to make sure that we can realize
the benefits of AI in a way that's safe
and secure and it seems a sensible and
reasonable step to just try and bring
some of those countries together to talk
about these problems you know in a
collective Forum because ultimately
there will need to be some coordination
so I think it's quite early thinking as
I said it's more just about bringing
people together who are countries
through together well it's just bringing
people together who are thinking about
these things in a in a similar way to
exchange ideas share information and as
I said because AI doesn't respect
National borders and I think we will all
benefit from hearing and talking to each
other in a conversation with the
businesses themselves and I think that
that is really what this is about I
think we're not we're a long way from
anyone establishing a
AIA IAA equivalent for AI those things
are you know long into the distance but
in the first instance just talking
through this with like-minded countries